(audience cheering and clapping)
- All right, all right, okay.
- That's not normal.
- Thank you.
- I mean, are y'all finished?
(audience cheering and clapping)
- I think they like you.
- Hey guys, good to see you too.
I think they're you've
got a couple fans here.
That doesn't happen, Nick.
I hope you feel really
good about yourself.
- Thank you all for that great welcome.
That was very nice.
- I know.
Well, thank you for being here.
How are things?
You look so fantastic.
- Thank you.
It's great to be here.
I feel like I'm here
like once a month now.
- I know.
- And it's really nice.
- I was going through trying to pick
- Just catching up.
- I give people vinyl and like
wine every time they come,
and I'm like, I've given
him like five vinyl.
I think I'm like, which did I
what did I not give him last time?
Anyway, hope it was new..
- Thank you for all the great gifts.
- Okay, you're welcome.
- It was new,
yeah it was new.
- I hope it was a new one.
I think it was, but whatever.
- It was.
- You deserve some congrats as well.
You're a daddy now.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah. That's so funny.
- [Nick] Pretty
- It's the first time you've been on here,
since you've been a daddy
- It's pretty wild.
Yeah, there she is.
- Yes.
- She's got a little heart face
- A little heart face.
- And she's the best.
It's just been a magical
season of our life,
and you know also pretty wild,
but it it's a blessing to have her home
and been wonderful lots,.
and you have a lot to celebrate?
- I do, yeah.
- Nine. Is it nine?
- Our show got nine Emmys.
(audience cheering)
- Weird, this so fun.
- This calls for a toast.
- Are we gonna drink?
I love when we drink on my show.
- Yeah, we always drink on it.
- Okay, okay.
(audience cheering)
Oh wait, okay.
Y'all had fabulous drinks
at your house when I came.
So wait, is this your,
- This is the same thing we drank.
- Is this your tequila?
- This is the tequila.
- This is good.
- Just seems right, ya know?
- It just feels like home.
It just, it's so good.
- It's so good.
- It's fancy fantastic
with this little number.
- Well, little blood orange
just really elevates the drink.
- I just had to drink again
to make sure I liked it.
So wait, are y'all able
to take a vacation,
or is it just like you and the Joe Bros
just hanging out at the residency?
Is that your vacation?
- Well we're having the residency
starting in a few days really,
which is very exciting.
- Yeah.
- And the whole idea for this show
was to build a really fan centric show.
And what I said, what I
mean is we want the fans
to be involved in every
step of the process,
from the curation of a set
list to the show itself,
you know and we're in a
season of our life and career,
I feel like where we're really focused
on just finding ways to
show our incredible fans
of now, you know 17, 18 years,
how much we appreciate their support. And
(audience cheering)
- That's so cool.
- And not to be clear,
not that we weren't
always appreciative of it,
but when you get, you know,
this far down the road,
and your life and career,
and you're thinking about
seeing some of those same faces,
and what that means to you as an artist.
It's just an incredible thing.
And so any way that we can
give back to the people
that have given us so much in this show
will mean a lot to us
and hopefully to them.
So that's what we're gonna do.
- I love that with the set list as well.
That's cool.
- Yeah.
And then to answer your
question, it's in Vegas.
So that's kind of our holiday
vacation for this year,
because we're pretty tied up otherwise.
But Vegas is a fun place to hang out.
- I was gonna say
- You know, not that I'll
be doing too much of that.
- I spend a lot of money
- Cause I'll be
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
you're gonna be tired
- But the other brothers'll have fun.
- So Colin Hanks was recently
on the show and well, he said this
- Someone came up to me and said,
what's up fake Nick Jonas?
- Fake Nick Jonas.
- And the reason why they said that
was because in "Jumanji",
I play like the main kid
that gets sucked into the game,
and in the game, I was
played by Nick Jonas.
- But in real life when you come back,
and you live your life,
- It's me.
- So in reality, he's fake Colin Hanks,
but no one calls him that
- That's rude.
(audience clapping)
- Now for the record,
I've never been called fake Colin Hanks.
- Oh, you've never been called that?
Oh, that's so interesting.
- But I just hope that
you don't confuse us,
'cause we've had a lot of history now.
- Totally.
I didn't, not at all.
Not at all.
Like I just, I, well, I mean, you
- Hold on.
This is the real test amongst friends.
- Wait, no.
- What am I?
What am I in your phone as?
- No, you were.
I mean,
- It's just Nick Jonas.
- [Kelly] Yeah, well
- It's just Nick Jones.
There's nothing.
There's no,
- No!
- Well
- Calling you now.
- No, it's totally.
Well, it might, it might.
- Okay.
- It might say
- That sounds
- [Kelly] It might say fake
Colin Hanks. (laughing)
(audience laughing and clapping)
- Look, look
- Okay.
- It was funny,
it was funny.
And I'm like,
- [Nick] No, it's really funny.
- No one calls you (laughing)
No one calls you fake Colin Hanks.
It's like my
- I won't be making my
monthly trip to your show.
- It's my only, it's my
- Kidding.
- Look, I'm the only one with
this really cool nickname.
- Yeah, yeah.
No, it's good
- Because nobody would, yeah
like you said, nobody does that
but it is funny that he
gets called fake Nick Jonas.
- I love him.
And I loved playing the
- [Kelly] fake Colin Hanks
- version of him in the game
and I've only ever met him once.
- Oh really?
- And we have played each other
twice now in two "Jumanjis".
- That's interesting.
- Yeah. So, and actually,
I have spent more time
with his parents than him.
- [Kelly] His parents are fun.
- Very fun.
- Yeah.
Love her.
Okay. So, and love him.
But last time you and
your brothers mentioned
that you were working on new music.
So asking for a friend,
what how's that going?
When am I gonna get some new music?
- We're usually like
really cryptic about this.
And I just kind of feel
like that's really stupid.
I don't know why we do that.
So we're working on new music for sure.
And I can tell you
(audience cheering)
- I'm excited.
I love y'alls music.
- I can tell you that.
I think it's my favorite
stuff we've ever done.
And it's, you know,
basically an evolution of the sound
in a way that I think is
really natural for us,
and feels like a great next step.
And we're working with some people
we've always wanted to work with.
And I can't wait for everyone to hear it.
(audience cheering)
- I know I said this last
time that y'all were here,
but I loved your show.
Like I had never been able to
like really watch a full show.
And it's so interesting
'cause we'd be on the voice,
and you forget, like you're
sitting next to like, I'm like
oh, you're like super talented.
Like I'm like, you, you just forget
'cause you're all just hanging out.
And I was at your show and I was like,
holy (beep)I know him.
I was like, it was just
so we can't say that on
daytime, but whatever.
But I was just freaking out
because y'all were so good.
It was, the songs were so good,
the energy was so good.
- That means a lot.
- The crowd, like loved it.
And I loved the fact
that the crowd was like
totally all different walks of life.
Like all different times.
That's my favorite kind of crowd,
where you're like nowhere
would you find these people.
That's my favorite kind of musical crowd.
- I agree with you.
- I feel like music can do that,
like bring randos together.
- Absolutely can,
and I feel like the fun thing
in this last couple years specifically,
has been that we've really
seen that distinction
of, you know beyond the kind of OG fans
who've been there forever.
To a lot of the older people
who have come into our shows,
perhaps watched "The
Voice" or other things.
And younger people who
are introduced to us
in the last couple years
and think we're a new band.
It's like
- Oh my God.
It's like this oh yeah,
- People think you're a new band.
That's my favorite thing that people do.
Like if I perform somewhere,
and they're like oh my gosh, you can sing.
And I'm like, well
like well a little.
And I'm like, but it is my favorite thing
'cause you know that person,
no, they didn't mean offense.
They just hadn't really heard anything.
And I'm like, okay, well thank you.
So let's talk about your new show.
So it's called "Dancing With Myself",
which I feel like I do
every night at my house.
So explain how it works.
- So I was approached to
join this show that Shakira
- Is this the show we were
talking about at dinner?
- Yeah.
- Okay, go..
- So Shakira had created and developed
over a couple year period where, you know,
so many people were at home
over the last couple years, during COVID
making videos of them dancing,
you know, following different trends
on TikTok or reals, whatever challenges.
And she had the great idea
to bring some of those people
into a competition setting,
where they have a chance to win $25,000,
at the end of each episode.
And we really spotlight people
who have a passion for dance.
And it's not about being the best dancer
or the most technical.
It's about your energy, your spirit
and what you bring to the table,
and also your dancing abilities.
But in the different rounds you know,
people get eliminated of course,
but we get to save a few.
So it's actually kind of
like the best part of our job
on "The Voice" is that moment
when we get to save somebody
and keep them in the competition.
That's our journey
throughout the whole show.
So I was actually, I was
thrilled to be there.
Shakira is amazing.
Lizza Koshi and,
- Love all of y'all.
- Great, it's a great panel.
And we had a great time.
- I love, on a serious note.
I do feel like dancing is so therapeutic.
Like I can be having the worst day ever,
and I put my kids to bed,
and then I literally put on music,
and I dance alone in my house.
But it feels so good 'cause it just,
it feels good to move your
body like that, anyway.
'Cause I don't like working out,
so I just choose to like dance.
- I'm with you.
- But on that note,
it's time for another break.
Nick's show is called
"Dancing With Myself".
It premieres May 31st on NBC.
Y'all gotta check it out.